en ces vacances de février les
restaurants d'altitude n'ont pas
toujours bonne réputation
du coup une trentaine d'établissements
suisse et en france se joue la carte de
la gastronomie ou presque une vraie
bonne assiette pour les skieurs à
l'heure du déjeuner de quoi redorer
l'image de la cuisine à la neige jean
jacques dufour karl gréco ketchup
snowboard hot dogs au fil des années la
montagne française c'est américaine mais
ils font des reds au cycle son superman
et train des sons et changera quoi que
non mais il ya aussi une demi heure pour
manger là bas
histoire de redorer le blason terni de
ces établissements disséminés sur les
sommets les responsables du domaine des
portes du soleil
douze stations et 220 remontés ont
décidé de lancer un pass bourg b c'est
un guide gratuit qui regroupe une
trentaine de restaurateurs qui eux
montrent leur savoir faire et c'est une
invitation à découvrir notre patrimoine
on a donc suivre le guide premier arrêt
sur les pistes avec le chef japonais de
la table du marché c'est uniquement la
cuisine française c'est quand même pour
moi c'est la meilleure chose la
meilleure du monde mario est tout à fait
alors c'est quoi votre spécialité vous
écoutez moi j'adore travailler poisson
mais quand même c'est un montant
supérieur basé cochons ne les cochons
soufflé au beaufort jeu les ducks un
risotto aux écrevisses sa cuisine c'est
mieux qu'une journée de glisse cette eau
ne prête pas de conte du drac est tout
ça il faut faire autre chose que
que ce qu'en fait le monde pour passer
d'un sommet au fond d'une vallée il
suffit de ski ça permet d'avaler des
kilomètres de pistes et d'arriver dans
une ferme où les jambes ont enfumé font
saliver avant même de les avoir goûtés
fait quoi dans la ferme alors là
maintenant elle fromage que vous vendez
oui et puis je tous les cochons jeu
fallait changer sont les bouder jean
rolin beau oui ferme ou resto rural ou
gastro l'opération pass gourmet c'est
l'alternative au mcdo d'ailleurs pour 15
euros
les estaminets impliqué propose une
assiette ce coeur qui devrait permettre
de se rabibocher avec la gastronomie des
sommets face vous mais c'est une fausse
est maman c'est une soupe à la viande
fumée avec georges légumes
chou rave c'est ce que manger les gens
tout à fait c'est un produit qui marche
très très bien avec les gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur parce qu'il
découvre justement les règles du quart
ce qui marche également très bien c'est
le steak de cheval au beurre de myrte
manger du cheval
nous aimons bien là cheval j'ai vu vous
aviez aussi ils font du au fond oui ça
c'est une création maison
nous l'avons inventé l'année passée
après avoir fait un rôti de porc au
point on devait faire une fondue j'ai
dit on fera qu une fondue original c'est
d'avoir etc sont tous sur les pistes
dans jour saucisses fait un nom mais
nous refusons tout ça nous refusons cela
étant et comme vous pouvez le constater
à la montagne comme ailleurs est lié à
pâques des gourmands mais pour ceux qui
aiment manger je peux en témoigner le
pass gourmet permet de déguster bien
autre chose que des frites surgelées